علينا من بيروت العميد الياس حنا الخبير
العسكري واستراتيجي العميد حنا ما الذي
تفهمه من تصريحات الرئيس الروسي عن تغيير
الاستراتيجيه العسكريه لموسكو وتوجيه
ضربات السباقيه كما تفعل واشنطن حسب مقال
جلال اولا ضربات الاستباقيه
لواشنطن هي ضربات تقليديه بعد 11 ايلول
للرئيس بوش اعلن الضربات السباقيه او
الحربقيه ونعرف الى ماذا ادت على حرب
الاستقباقيه ان كان في العراق او في
افغانستان اليوم عندما نتحدث عن العقيده
النوويه الروسيه هي عقيده اصلا موجوده وهي
دفاعيه وحتى الاسبوع الماضي او خلال هذا
الاسبوع تحدث الرئيس بوتين انها للرد انها
للدفاع ولكن بين التقليدي دائما وبين
النووي هناك ترابط في مكان ما النووي يخدم
التقليدي خاصه اذا بتقليد العدو بدا يهدد
الامن القومي الروسي وحده الاراضي
وبالتالي يمكن استعمال النووي ولكن لا
يمكن تغيير عقيده خلال حرب دائره تستلزم
الامور تجارب محاكاه ورجلين كما يقال
وامور كثيره جلال
همم ايضا نعقد الياس في الحديث عن
التقليدي والنوعي في الاسلحه اشار ايضا
الرئيس الروسي للصواريخ التي وصف بانها
اكثر حداثه وكفاءه من تلك التي تمتلكها
واشنطن يتحدث هنا عن التي تفوق سرعه الصوت
ما الذي نفهمه هنا من اشارتي لهذه
الصواريخ تحديدا
مريم كل الصواريخ ان كان البلاستيكيه او
الفرض صوتيه هي اكبر من سرعه الصوت اليوم
الفرق بين صواريخ البالستيه والصواريخ
الفرض صوتيه هي في المسار الذي تتبعه
وصولا الى الهداف في الحموله وبالتالي في
الارتفاع عن سطح الارض والصعب وصعب اعتراض
لها نحن اليوم نتحدث عن جهه معينه ولا
نعرف ماذا لدى الجهه الاخرى ودائما مريم
المعركه والصحه المعركه هي الاختبار
الاساسي يعني فلنستذكر كيف فكر العالم في
الجيش الروسي قبل الحرب على اوكرانيا وكيف
نفكر اليوم في اداء هذا الجيش العميد في
وقت تجمعون انتم كخبراء على ان هناك حاله
من الجمود في الجبهه بين همم روسيا
واوكرانيا سيامه في المناطق الشرقيه
والجنوبيه يبرز دائما تحذيرات من حلف شمال
الاطلسي من امكانيه تحول هذه الى حرب اوسع
كيف تفهمون هذا
هو دائما التصعيد جلال هو رساله سياسيه
لضبط الامور التكليكيه والعملانيه على
الجبهه فلنستذكر سقوط الصواريخ في بولندا
وكيف تدخل الرئيس بيضا من بالي اندونيسيا
لخفض حده التوتر وكانه المعركه هناك خطوط
معينه وخطوط تواصل بين المعنيين تدار هذه
المعركه بالمفهوم التكتيكي والعملان كي لا
تخرج عن هذه الضوابط لا اعتقد ان اي احد
يريد الذهاب الى حرب نوويه او الذهاب الى
حرب شامله وكامله في اوروبا شكرا العميد
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي في بيروت